Getting a
new glimpse
inside the roller coaster
relationship between former Hous
Speaker Kevin McCarthy and forme
President Donald Trump.
Today,
The Washington Post
is reporting a phone call
between Trump and McCarthy
after McCarthy was ousted
from the speakership.
The reporting is during the call
Trump lambasted McCarthy
for not expunging his two impeac
and not endorsing him in the 202
presidential campaign.
That's according to people famil
with the conversation.
Quote F you.
McCarthy is claimed to have
then told Trump,
I want to bring back our panel
on this,
including land Cold War, because
this is your reporting.
Very interesting that he is here
McCarthy is telling people
that he told the former presiden
to blank off.
Yeah, that's absolutely right.
And so the McCarthy team says
there were no curse words that w
But this is how McCarthy is reco
this conversation.
And it was a tense conversation
in the sense that McCarthy said,
why didn't you save me?
Why didn't you do anything
when I was being ousted?
And Trump said, well,
why didn't you endorse me?
Why haven't you expunged my impe
And so it was a very tense phone
But my colleague
Paul Kane
reminded me this morning
that this is a similar interpret
that McCarthy had after January
when he said that he
had a
very, you know, cursed out the p
after January six saying,
what were you doing?
What were you thinking?
And then the president had said
on the record
that, no,
that was not how that phone call
So it was very interesting
in their relationship.
They have talked
and they have texted since,
our sources tell us.
And also the relationship
between Trump and McCarthy
has always been on again and off
Sometimes it's codependent
and sometimes it's
not on great.
Codependent
I feel like there's one picture
speaks volumes about that
term codependent.
And I don't even need
to probably explain to Mike.
There you go.
I don't even need to say it
to the control room
because everybody
knows what I'm talking about.
Codependent.
January the end of January, 20,
After you said Leann that he rec
some tough words with the
president former president
he goes down to Mar a Lago and.
He thinks
he might as well have been holdi
raft there
because that's what Kevin McCart
was giving
to former president Donald Trump
something 22 days after the insu
a week after he left office.
Trump was on the verge
of becoming isolated
and marginalized by Republicans.
And Kevin McCarthy revived him,
resuscitated it.
And here we are.
But loyalty is a one way street.
As the former speaker is pointin
McCarthy also spoke at the New Y
DealBook summit and talked
more about it in his own words
we have about his relationship
with Donald Trump,
he said,
I have an interesting relationsh
with Trump.
I do not criticize him on televi
because I don't think it's right
And I know it drives him crazy.
And I don't know
I'll have any influence if you d
But my personal conversations wi
we have
very clear personal conversation
Right. Right.
Well, interesting
I think we can all agree
that that's accurate,
that they do have very interesti
interactions.
But, you know,
like Jeff said, it's just
there are so many other instance
you know, loyalty has not transl
for Donald Trump
in the way that you would think.
Because if Kevin McCarthy is
the person
who is broadly credited
or blamed for resuscitating Trum
after the insurrection,
then you would think that partic
when McCarthy
is having his own political trou
that Trump would exert
some of that influence over Hous
Republicans in terms of trying t
Kevin McCarthy in power.
But he didn't do that.
And they are where they are.
And it's just you're
the reporting was fascinating.
It's just another chapter in chr
this very up and down relationsh
that we've seen for some time no
While we're on the subject
of Kevin McCarthy,
we talked about the balance of p
in the context of George Santos.
And if he is ousted,
the Republicans will have one fe
Question is also
whether Kevin McCarthy is going
Obviously, very different
reasons from Jorge Santos.
Let's just
remind people you
see on the screen there,
two 22 to two 13.
Here's another thing
that McCarthy said on that topic
To The New York Times.
If I decide to run again,
I have to know my heart it
in my heart, I'm giving 110%.
I have to know that I want to do
I also have to know
if I'm going to walk away,
that I'm going to be fine
with walking away.
If you just got thrown out of sp
you go through different stages,
would you not?
And then you got to turn around
and make a decision.
Yeah.
So the decision time is coming
in California.
You have until December 8th
to file for reelection
because he's an incumbent.
He's given an extra five days.
So he has until December 13th.
And my sources tell me that he i
he is seriously contemplating le
but he hasn't made that decision
Okay, guys, thanks.
Great discussions, great reporti